ankommen katrin hat viele kontakte vor
ort wir wollen mit ihr sprechen und mit
elmar theveßen unserem usa korrespondent
der uns versorgen wird mit informationen
die er aus dem pentagon in den usa
gehört hat und wir wollen nun schalten
auch direkt nach taschkent usbekistan zu
meiner kollegin katrin eigendorf wenn
sie uns schon zugeschaltet ist und mit
ihr darüber sprechen was los ist in
kabul in afghanistan wir warten noch
einen moment bis das funktioniert wir
wollen also einordnen wie die lage vor
ort ist hat eine explosion mindestens
eine explosion gegeben jetzt die serie
warten doch das kann und darf ich höre
sie ich höre dich und ich sehe dich auch
katrin was hörst du von deinen kontakten
vor ort wie ist die situation dort
gerade
also meine kontakte vor ort mit denen
ich gesprochen habe die kommen jetzt
nicht ganz direkt an den flughafen ran
aber es scheint so zu sein dass an dem
gate zwei explosionen gegeben hat es
scheint ein selbstmordattentäter hat
sich in die luft gesprengt zu haben das
sind die informationen die wir bisher
haben
man muss sich vorstellen die situation
am flughafen kabul ist sehr
unübersichtlich das ist ein
riesengelände mit sehr vielen eingängen
die alle von ganz unterschiedlichen
kräften kontrolliert werden da gibt es
einen eingang da steht hauptsächlich
amerikanisches militär an anderen
kontrolliert auch die afghanische armee
andere teile des flughafens werden von
taliban kontrolliert es hat ja in den
letzten tagen immer wieder warnungen
gegeben sowohl die usa als auch
deutschland und großbritannien hatten ja
ihre bürger wiederholt aufgefordert
nicht an den flughafen zu geben weil es
eine terror warnung gegeben hat
möglicherweise könnte es einen anschlag
des islamischen des sogenannten
islamischen staates geben eine erklärt
verfeindete terrorgruppe der taliban
aber wir wissen bisher noch nicht was
der hintergrund ist ist es hat sich auch
noch niemand zu diesem anschlag heute
hier bekannt was klar ist das eigentlich
und mehr die sicherheitslage an diesem
flughafen wirklich kontrollieren kann
also da können leute einfach durch es
gibt keine wirkliche kontrolle mehr das
ist jetzt heute die lage in kabul am
flughafen vielen dank katrin bis hierhin
wir sprechen gleich nochmal wollen jetzt
aber schalten zu unserem
usa-korrespondent elmar theveßen nach
washington der für uns die details aus
dem pentagon hat denn heute wollte sich
dann auch der sprecher des pentagons mit
mehr details melden emma ist dazu schon
etwas bekannt
ja es gibt noch kein offizielles
briefing vom pentagon hier in washington
aber einzelne informationen sekunde
heraus sind auch offiziell bestätigt
also es hat in der tat am gate das ist
ein eingangsbereich im südwesten des
flughafens kabul eine explosion gegeben
es deutet viel darauf hin dass es ein
selbstmordanschlag war so bestätigen
auch die us behörden möglicherweise gab
es einen zweiten anschlag eine zweite
explosion in der nähe an einem hotel dem
sogenannten berlin hotel das ist der ort
an dem sich vor allen dingen us
staatsbürger und afghanen die den
us-truppen geholfen haben in den letzten
jahren sammeln sollten um dann in den
flughafen gebracht zu werden diese
explosionen zu hören wir aus dem
pentagon haben opfer gefordert die
genaue zahl ist noch unklar es deutet
einiges darauf hin dass es tote gegeben
hat es ist von mehr als zehn toten
insgesamt die rede aus verschiedenen
quellen zum beispiel eine der quellen
sind die taliban selber ein
taliban-sprecher hat das mitgeteilt wir
wissen dass es eine hohe anzahl an
verletzten ganz offenbar gegeben hat das
ist auch bestätigt dass unter den
verletzten mehrere us staatsbürger sein
sollen wir wissen nicht genau ob es
soldaten sind die an diesem geld sind
oder konsularbeamte dieses geld am
flughafen kabul wird in der tat genutzt
in den letzten tagen um eben die
menschen die evakuiert werden sollen
hineinzubringen in den flughafen dort
stehen in der regel us soldaten
teilweise auch mit anderen streitkräften
aus anderen ländern die den flughafen
schützen und dorthin kommen eben viele
dieser evakuierten dort stehen auch
konsularbeamte gleich bereit also es hat
ganz offenbar verletzte gegeben die in
form schonen die hier in washington
vorlegen deuten darauf hin dass es nicht
nur explosionen gegeben hat sondern auch
schießereien es ist deswegen unklar ob
es jetzt schießereien sind die
unmittelbar mit diesen attacken zu tun
hatten in kabul wenn ja dann würde das
darauf hindeuten dass möglicherweise
eine koordinierte aktion stattgefunden
hat also dass man versucht hat die
sicherheitssperren zu durchbrechen und
man muss glaube ich dazu sagen und dazu
wissen dass die taliban in erster linie
mit mehreren checkpoints rund um den
flughafen eine art der perimeter
geschaffen haben bei dem sie oder an dem
sie den zugang zum flughafen bereich
kontrollieren das heißt die taliban
selber tragen momentan mit dazu bei dass
es sicherheit gibt rund um den flughafen
und ganz offenbar ist dieser
sicherheitsring durchbrochen worden
durch die möglichen attentäter die diese
anschläge in kabul heute verübt haben
wir lesen hier in einer eil meldung von
reuters das auch einer der us-truppen
dabei verletzt sein soll das ist bislang
in eine meldung von reuters die us
truppen der usa wollten eigentlich noch
bis am dienstag ihre evakuierungsflüge
fliegen und somit auch sicherstellen
dass dann noch mehrere menschen aus dem
land kommen was wie schätzt du dass ein
wie wird sich das jetzt auch vielleicht
auswirkungen auf diese
evakuierungsaktion der usa und der
anderen internationalen truppen in
afghanistan
es hängt davon ab ob die lage
tatsächlich im griff ist nach diesen
anschlägen also sichergestellt werden
kann dass man diesen diesen ring um das
um den flughafen kabul einigermaßen
wieder herstellen kann aber es gibt
überhaupt keinen zweifel daran dass die
weitere evakuierung akut gefährdet ist
denn es bedeutet ja dass menschen wieder
aus der stadt herr zum flughafen kommen
müssen die amerikaner schätzen dass noch
etwa 500 us staatsbürger ausgeflogen
werden müssten die auch raus wollen sie
haben keine angaben über 1000 weitere us
bürger die sich möglicherweise noch in
afghanistan aufhalten und da sind
natürlich die vielen hilfskräfte und es
geht natürlich nicht nur um die für die
gearbeitet haben für die amerikaner
sondern auch für andere unter anderem
die deutschen
es sieht danach aus dass einige flüge
schon eingestellt werden jetzt weil die
evakuierung aus zum beispiel deutscher
sicht weitgehend abgeschlossen ist also
es gibt eine meldung aus berlin dass die
deutschen flüge hiermit eigentlich jetzt
schon beendet sind aber natürlich hatten
die usa unter anderem gehofft in den
nächsten 2-3 tagen noch weitere flüge zu
starten um evakuierte mindestens vom
flughafen weg zu bringen das steht jetzt
natürlich ein stück weit in frage der
präsident im weißen haus ist gebrieft
worden er sitzt zusammen mit seinem
nationalen sicherheitsteam und wir
werden wahrscheinlich in sehr naher
zukunft aus dem pentagon und dann noch
weitere details auch über das weitere
vorgehen der amerikaner in kabul
erfahren
neben dank einem aktivisten bis hierhin
dankeschön wir werden uns vielleicht
dann später noch mal sprechen jetzt
möchten wir noch einmal nachfragen bei
unserer unserer reporterin katrin
eigendorf in taschkent in usbekistan
sie hat viele kontakte vor ort hatte
eben schon erwähnt dass die situation am
flughafen in kabul schon zuvor äußerst
chaotisch war kathrin wenn du uns gleich
jetzt nochmal zugeschaltet ist jetzt
sehe ich und höre dich kennt die
situation am flughafen war schon vorher
sehr sehr schwierig wie war das
abzusehen also viele haben davon unter
forschung gewarnt dass so etwas auch
passieren könnte richtig
ja es hat zahlreiche warnungen gegeben
und immer wieder die aufforderung vom
flughafen weg zu bleiben das große
problem in der stadt ist momentan dass
die taliban die sich dort in der stadt
befinden und dort die macht übernommen
haben zu einem ganz ganz großen teil von
außerhalb kommen also nicht von kabul
dass sie sich selber in der stadt nicht
gut auskennen dass es sich bei diesen
sogenannten checkpoints nicht um
systematische kontrollen handelt sondern
einfach um irgendwelche kämpfer die sich
an straßen postieren leute kontrollieren
teilweise terrorisieren das sind ja
keine systematischen kontrollen das was
man wirklich eine sicherheit nennt die
das stattfinden und es zeigt sich eben
dass sie das auch nicht wirklich
garantieren können dass die möglichkeit
besteht dass der selbstmordattentäter an
den flughafen herankommen sich unter die
menge mischen die lage am flughafen rund
um flughafen ist wirklich nicht unter
kontrolle und das macht und gefährdet
die weitere evakuierungen natürlich weil
alle internationalen streitkräfte die da
im flughafen jetzt noch operieren sind
natürlich auch bedroht also man mag sich
gar nicht vorstellen was jetzt wirklich
sagen man einen gruss organisierter
terroranschlag bewirken könnte welchen
schaden der anrichten könnte wir kennen
jetzt bis jetzt noch nicht die
hintergründe von von diesem anschlag das
wird sich sicherlich jetzt in der
nächsten halben stunde etwas klarer
herausstellen aber klar ist dieser
flughafen ist alles andere als sicher
und die evakuierung von menschen ja sehe
ich im moment wirklich in frage ob das
weiter jetzt so zügig gehen kann wie das
eigentlich geplant war
ist damit zu rechnen dass dadurch jetzt
vielleicht noch weitere panik entsteht
wir hatten ja schon auch zuvor in den
letzten tagen immer wieder chaotische
szenen vor dem flughafen in kabul vor
der mauer menschen die dabei verletzt
worden sind könnte das jetzt noch zu
mehr panik dort führen
im moment ist es schwer darüber ein bild
zu gewinnen weil ich habe niemanden von
meinen gesprächspartnern der jetzt
wirklich direkt daran ist aber sie sagen
mir dass ungefähr noch 10.000 menschen
sich da an diesem flughafen aufhalten
teilweise ohne papiere die herren da ja
teilweise auch schon über eine woche aus
die kommen hingegen zurückgehen wieder
nach hause laden ihre handys auf
versuchen irgendwie in diesen flughafen
reinzukommen und das wird ebenso hören
wir auch von von von internationalen
sicherheitsfirmen immer schwieriger auch
selbst leute die regulär dort begleitet
hinkommen wollen dorthin zu geleiten
weil wie gesagt die sicherheitslage ist
alles andere als übersichtlich und mit
diesem anschlag hat sich das eigentlich
noch mal bestätigt es ist immens
gefährlich an diesem flughafen
heranzukommen und diese evakuierung wird
man wirklich ist noch mal überlegen
müssen wie man die versucht sicherer zu
machen
vielen dank für die einordnung bis dahin
katrin eigendorf dankeschön
das sind die meldungen die aktuellen
meldungen die wir bislang haben die wir
bislang einordnen konnten wir behalten
jetzt die situation natürlich weiter im
blick mehr ist zurzeit noch nicht
bekannt danke für eure aufmerksamkeit
dass ihr zugeschaltet habt und wir
beobachten die lage weiter
[Musik]